In a leadership position.
Is it okay to take or ask for suggestions
on solving a task or is it okay to
take suggestions that
stray from my initial plan?
Yes.
And I hope that this,
that would made you decide to ask this
questions cause you just like found out
about the podcast or the book
or whatever because this is,
this is something that absolutely anybody
that kind of listens will would say
yes, absolutely. You're
in a leadership position.
You should definitely ask for suggestions,
take suggestions, share the
planning, let other people lead.
Many brains be smarter
than your one brain.
That's what you want. You want to
utilize the brain power of your team.
Now the reason you're asking
this question, little bit scary,
a little bit of a red flag.
The reason you're asking this question
because you were afraid of what it'll
look like. If you have to ask, hey
guys, I'm not sure how to do this,
or you're afraid of of what it
means that you're going to look,
that you're going to look weak,
you're going to look like a weak leader,
and that's definitely, yeah,
you're going an experience.
That's your insecurity that's making
that happened. Don't be insecure.
Don't be in secure because the open
mind and asking for suggestions and the
taking suggestions, it actually
makes you look like a better leader.
I know that sounds crazy.
It actually makes you look like a better
leader when you say, Hey, you know what?
Echo, we got this promise
off. Not a hundred percent
sure how to tackle this one.
Can you give me a hand?
Can you give me some suggestions
here that doesn't make you say, oh,
Jocko doesn't know his game. He's an
idiot. No, it goes, aw man. Jockos humble.
He's looking for input.
He wants to work together as a team.
Okay,
so yes,
absolutely.
Ask for suggestions, take
suggestions. Have an open mind.
Disregard your plan.
If your plan wasn't good,
I'm not just going to hold fast to a plan
because I'm the one that thought of it.
That's not good leadership at all.
Don't do that.
Open your mind.
Yup.